20:16 it's been an amazing year for
high-risk Studios smites had one of its
strongest years ever and we just
recently took paladin's into open beta
and now we want to show you guys
something new that we've been working on
we're huge fans here at the studio of
tactical games of turn-based games
something we want to do for a very long
time it's very exciting to be able to
make a game in that genre in the smite
universe
it's my tactics all started out as a
paper prototype they started making like
basically a board game and just playing
around that and I saw it I was like
instantly hooked and interested
after the initial PC played test
everyone realized how awesome the game
was and we decided to move forward with
it there's a wide variety of cards and
smite tactics we wanted to make sure
that everyone was building synergies
based on gods and minions we really felt
that they really captured the light
there's Mike but somewhere to smite the
real stars of the show are the gods each
God and smite tactics has a unique
active ability that goes on a turn-based
cooldown when you use these abilities
not only capture the spirit of the god
and smite itself but also allow the
player more control on again so the
coolest things we get to do is put more
effort into attack animations and
ability animations in smite we are very
strict on the timings for all the
animations so in this it's not just
quick swipes it's actually big long
attacks not only the god characters we
have to do a lot of the creeps and the
minions because you summon them and you
control them two main are important in
this game we've gained a lot of
experience from developing smite for
multiple platforms and so with tactics
we're definitely building it from ground
up to be an amazing experience with
either keyboard or controller I like
that it's a lot because it's mainly
positioning not just the guard you draw
so I
it's actually gonna be great for playing
in between rain qs+ it'll be fun for
those of you that stream of the YouTube
content to always be playing a game for
you sir this is the project that has
been very near and dear to me and I
can't wait to see you guys play it
because we have put a whole lot of work
into it it's a game that I'm really
passionate about I'm often that people
really enjoy it we got to be starting
closed testing towards the end of the
year and we can't wait you guys to see
more of the game
you